ladies and gentlemen the declaration a
result for the Auckland South pasture
constituency I Ellen Macpherson
returning officer for the UK
parliamentary election in awful and
South pasture constituency hereby give
notice that the total number of votes
pulled for each candidate at the
election was as followers Taz Mena I
made shake Scottish National Party
twenty six thousand twenty six thousand
six hundred and twenty Gordon banks
Scottish Liberal Party 16450 to
look Patrick grim Scottish conservative
and unionist
11980 seven
Martin gray UK Independence Party 1331
illion Stefan off Scottish Liberal
Democrats 1481 I declared that despina
are made shake is elected to serve in
the United Kingdom Parliament as the
member for the Opel and South pasture
constituency the number of ballot papers
rejected is as follows want of official
mark zero voting for more than one
registered party eleven writing or
marked by which water could be
identified sixty-four unmarked or void
for uncertainty zero so as a correction
Lee I think that's the other way around
zero writing or mark by which water can
be identified and 64 for unmarked to
avoid uncertainty making a total of 75
thank you
can I begin by thanking the returning
officer all staff and police for the
conduct of the count and can I also pay
tribute to my fellow candidates Gordon
banks Luke Graham
Elian stefa north and Martin gray I'd
also like to thank my outstanding
campaign team with the tremendous work
that they have done over the past few
weeks and in particular my amazing
election agent ellen forsen and of
course my ever supportive ever-present
husband Sofie thank you I would like to
thank the people of this constituency
for placing their faith in me and their
faith in the SNP whether you voted SNP
or not and whatever your views on
Scotland's future I will seek to
represent everyone in this constituency
to the very best of my ability this
election is about making the voice of
ocol and South Persia and the whole of
Scotland heard more effectively at
Westminster than ever before and I will
do everything I can to build unity as I
go about this important task you have
entrusted me with I pledge to use this
voice not just to improve Scotland but
to pursue progressive politics for the
benefit of people across the UK if
tonight I have been elected alongside a
strong group of SNP MPs we will work to
put an end to the austerity cuts which
are hurting people in communities north
and south of the border we will call for
the Paris promise to Scotland and the
referendum starting with those which
make the biggest impact in getting more
people into work and making work pay and
as part of a strong group of SNP MPs I
will always vote
wasting 100 billion pounds on renewing
trident by ending austerity and
scrapping trident we can choose to
invest in the things that really matter
to the people of Scotland like our
National Health Service the people of
Scotland are speaking and it's time for
their voice to be heard at Westminster
thank you